looking for good after nearly six months
teaching prisoners to cook in Brixton
prison
I'm still trying to persuade a major
retailer to stock a lemon treacle slice
if a big order comes in my remaining
workforce need to deliver but I've just
found out I'm about to lose yet another
valuable member of my team
heroin addict Paul wires were senders to
eight months for stealing 50 quids worth
of stake from Sainsbury's to pay for his
drug habit after being in prison for
four months he's just been approved to
release don't start taking drugs
thinking young and have be a junkie
you think you can control it hopefully
anyone can really deep that I've
witnessed my younger brother triumph
failed to go clean countless times so
spoken to my restaurant manager had the
Savoy Grill and decided to give Paul a
chance
I can't give you a job just like that
yeah within 48 hours that's just not
going to happen but what I am gonna do
next week is arrange for a trial to
spend a day in the kitchen and if you do
keep your head down stay focused and you
prove to me to my head chef and it goes
very well there's a job at the end of it
I don't want you in limbo because that's
where the temptation starts and I've
been close to it for 15 years and I can
tell you every rehab every secondary
house every halfway house every program
and every pickup for meth within 25 mile
radius of London let me tell you you're
the only person who can screw this up
and if you do oh yeah
what can I charge a lunch bro when Paul
left school he studied at college to
become a chef but he didn't finish the
course this is his big chance it's all
shut up just takes me over dinner in my
member yeah let's say so yeah I can't
wait and it's just gonna keep keep me
motivated or even better
if Paul sticks to his word I'll be
working with him on the outside
I'm hoping the bad boys bakery's loss
will be the Safari grills gain at last
there's been a promising development for
the trick or slice hi sorry oh come on
it's Gordon Ramsay how are you while my
team will be working on the recipe to
make it less sweet i wrangled a phone
call with Sarah Carter the marketer
Director of National Coffee chain
caffeine arrow we're looking to take to
the next level because this place has to
stay open it can't stay open unless it
can sustain a business that's the bottom
line
consistency is key to pre-show that
that's great news I was a brilliant lead
I'll get that appointment sorted and
getting to see Paul and take him a a
couple of samples bingo I mean that is
bloody good news she's got me a meeting
with the head of developments Paul so
it's [ __ ] great news
Paul Ettinger has the power to decide
which new products go into the companies
500 outlets
that's music my ears but I mean now
pressures on because that is a big door
that's been open so now we have to
perfect that slice now it has to be you
know there's no thin crust thick crust
it has to be absolutely consistent